Film Courage: I’m hoping we can talk about
a character with a goal and a character with
no goal.
And how will I be able to see that my screenplay
has a character with a weak goal?
Naomi Beaty, Writer, Screenwriting Teacher
and Consultant: Interesting.
I think most movies mainstream movies that
you watch are really built around a character
pursuing something right?
I would say they all have pretty definable
goals.
Any movie that you see that is in the theater…I
take that back…not any movie that you see…most
movies that you see are designed around somebody
who wants something very badly and goes after
it, right?
I would say if you’re trying to figure out
whether your character has a weak goal probably
the places that I would start is at your Break
in [Act] 2, this is assuming you have already
written the script.
At your break into 2 do we know what your
character is going to be pursuing over the
rest of the movie.
That is their goal.
You might not always think of it as a goal.
You might think of it as just a conflict like
this character and this character are competing
for the same prize or something like that.
You could look at it that way.
But we know what we are tracking over that
entire movie.
So I would say establishing that goal is one
part of the question that you are asking.
And the other part is whether they are pursuing
that goal and we want them to be pursuing
it consistently and against great odds and
opposition right throughout the entire movie.
That is something that you’d have to evaluate,
is my character in virtually every scene are
they pursuing that goal, that big picture
thing that they are trying to accomplish.
If they are, are they also running into some
form of antagonism that is keeping them from
making progress too quickly or achieving that
goal right away without anything standing
in their way because we want both of those
things because we want a strong goal but we
also want your character to pursue it actively
and really try to get it.
Film Courage: With the movie BRIDESMAIDS if
we go back to that movie as an example and
we look at her goals [Annie played by Kristen
Wiig)] is the goal to win the friendship of
the friend [Lillian played by Maya Rudolph]
or show up the other woman [Helen played by
Rose Byrne]?
Naomi: Well I would say that they goal in
that movie is to be her best friends Maid
of Honor.
And the method (remember we talked about the
method) that she is going to use is by competing
with Helen.
She won’t always have to compete with Helen
in order to achieve that goal but that’s
her main force of antagonism so she really
is going to have to compete with Helen most
of the time.
I would say what is at stake in that movie
is her friendship among other things but we
are just sort of laying out the building blocks
of the set up.
That’s how I would kind of delineate them.
Does that make sense?
Film Courage: It does.
So if I am writing a script and someone is
not clear on why my character is doing certain
things, does that indicate that the hero’s
goal is not very clear?
Naomi: If we know what they are trying to
do then I would say the goal is clear but
if we are not sure why they are doing something
I would say either there is sort of a plot
logic problem like we don’t understand why
they think this thing is what they need to
do or it could also be a stakes problem.
We don’t understand why they are taking
on this goal in the first place because we
don’t understand what it means to them or
what will happen if they don’t take it on
or what happens if they fail.
All of those things we need to really understand
the motivation behind your character’s actions
and a lot of times that has to do with stakes.